my name is none of those are my name
none of those are my name hi guys my
name is persona if you don't know now
you know your life is different now
today we are cooking in the kitchen
because that's what you do in the
kitchen what else to do in the kitchen
I don't know stand up on your
refrigerator and eat whatever looks kind
of edible at 4 a.m. just wearing a cloak
of shame yeah we're not doing that
though we're cooking today last week and
I attempted to make falafel I have never
made swappable for and it turned out
below average which I'm exceptionally
proud of but then I cannot make falafel
more interesting because when I cook
things on this channel I try to make it
dumber than what its intended for and I
thought AHA what's the dumbest food of
all times a hot dog which is ironic
because recently I designed and sold hot
dog pocket teas I'm represent calm and
they are back for the next couple days
I'm represent calm great like I would
show you the one that I own but I wore
too many days in their own it's actually
disgusting so go represent that concept
it's great seven to order your hot dogs
here right now excuse me
that was my transition I wanted a chance
to redeem myself in making falafel and I
wanted to make it dumber
today I'm making some sort of falafel
hot dog or what I am calling a [ __ ] Tina
because falafel is mostly chickpeas and
hot dogs are often referred to as
wieners so it's tricky I know it's a
great title I thought of it
Basel would usually come in fall for
there's going to be a lot of dick
innuendo so please Park your dick
bicycles right now and settle in I went
on Pinterest and I found a basic falafel
recipe and I'm going to try to do that
and then shape them instead of involved
form into Wiener form because there's a
difference also I thought about food
prepping this video and then I just
didn't we a cup of chopped red onion I
should wash my hands but honestly the
dirtiest thing on me is my mouth let me
wash that too chickpea nurse also this
is not a shot glass this is a container
for a votive candle and I up
so scared of it I'm here to give you
important life hacks assuming we chop it
tiny that's a technical term that lots
of chefs use just chop it tiny don't
forgot that I didn't wash my hands
you're not eating this I mean thank you
for watching my video I'm pretty awesome
at having a lot of tolerance to chopping
onions I think it's because I don't have
feelings like axe while I'm getting the
recipe from family food on the table
calm I love my family
where's my dog bringing her oven to 400
degrees onions set aside four cloves of
garlic okay girl like you're molding so
much oh my god are you okay context is
recording think take me down to the
paranoid city but the grass is green and
grace is theater job one way I learned
to peel garlic is from Rachael Ray where
you just hit it with a knife you'll just
comes right off Oh garlic smells like
garlic leave a comment down below if
you've ever seen garlic it looks like
chopped garlic cool it's a sticky that's
what he and she said I also need two
cans of chickpeas I got them right here
I'm going to open them up and drain them
which is how I experience relationships
I got this weird ass can opener that
took me like two weeks to learn how to
use goes like that right then you look
at this you're like that's not I can't
what this isn't an open can this thing's
got these teeny tiny little pinchers on
the side it's just like a parent lid
comes off with that and this is a outlet
it's not dull it's also a dragon sounded
like someone puking into a fan so I ran
for sure I hate taking a shower now your
turn we needed 1/4 cup of loosely packed
parsley and a half cup of loosely packed
cilantro that's exactly how I described
every travel scenario that I get ready
for race are you ready to go I loosely
pack you want to chop this up so I'm
gonna chop up anyway why did I chop this
up it's all going to get chopped up in a
food processor anyway which by the way I
just realized I don't really have a food
processor I have a very tiny one and
this is all way too much to put it all
together so plz but we have to combine
the chickpeas the red onion the garlic
the cilantro and the parsley in a food
processor and let it process until it's
kind of still chunky so I have this very
tiny Cuisinart kinda dirty but you're
not eating this all of these
to fit into this I'm going to have and
do two rounds of this process it's what
half of the chickpeas and half of this
one cup of red onion in expansion kind
of shove some down I've got the garlic
okay can you play nice together I think
I stopped this screw I just wanted to
assume that everything's going to work
out an optimist or an idiot
y'all are sucking a dick right now and
it's not my fault if your time on
everybody
I'm going to use my magic bullet come
here buddy oh boy I'm just going to go
old school look at this look at all
combines together isn't this amazing
isn't that noise amazing
okay so I've also decided I only need
half of this recipe I'm not making this
meal for anyone but myself
it's disgusting maybe so I'm not going
to do the second half of this and before
I put this on the magic bullet it says
to combine the rest of the ingredients
so I'm just going to do that right now
let's do it we have a tablespoon of
olive oil okay half a tablespoon of
lemon juice right half a tablespoon of
ground cumin cool a teaspoon of ground
coriander that sounds like what a
celebrity would name their child
half a teaspoon and don't know what
measurement means from salt half a
teaspoon of baking soda which thank God
this recipe called for baking soda
because it made me realize I have not
changed the baking soda in my
refrigerator since November you should
change your baking soda every thirty
days since the box of baking soda thank
you Pinterest falafel recipe yes there's
way too much now we mix it well honestly
I feel like on The Bachelor of cooking
appliances I have my hometown date with
Cuisinart now it's your turn magic
bullet let's do it he's be interesting
and cool
I need to add more oil all right well at
this point
actually it's skids nothing needs to be
ground anymore I'm just going to mix it
maybe this is a metaphor for the
bachelor I didn't need you guys I could
love myself enough to feel good all
along but give it spin some a gluon
finland so our falafel mixture is
completely mixed together after only a
very easy 50 minute
baking sheet and now this is the part
where you would normally for me falafels
into falafel balls but we're going to
form into wieners so we can get some
chickpea nerd wait I got a oh no I saw
when I spray the baking sheet now we
form it into wiener oh this is not going
to turn out okay nothing is some chunky
it's extremely moist this is just a mush
pop and that's my foreplay this is gonna
be bad maybe not let's hope okay smell
really good but also my sense of smell
is pretty awful we're going to bake them
for 20 minutes I mean you know that's
cool we'll look cooking this is what
they look like and be beautiful no
one-size shame them okay we're putting
them in the oven for 20 minutes but
laughs so I'm going to do some like free
evaluations in the next 20 minutes talk
amongst yourself select the settings are
a little different everything got
different it's been 20 minutes rinse
hair falafel out of the oven and flip it
to the other side and then cook it for
another 10 to 15 minutes oh you guys
look okay
oh it's bring you to where the people
can see you out when you're hot damn it
can sit the out hot you're all beautiful
pictures no flip you over these seem
pretty dry can't wait
nothing like a dry cleaner now back in
the oven for 10 to 15 minutes okay
yes oh please yeah it touched it
haha really did a handle we have our
Weiner S shaped falafel so now we're
just going to make a hot dog Santa dog
stuffed falafel let's do it we got hot
bun and you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want with it there's no rules and this
recipe that I've been using to make this
falafel shows you how to make a sashimi
sauce with lemon and water and some
other things but I just got this garlic
spread oh I'm sorry
raw garlic fluffy spread literally
overall garlic
fluffy spread vegan but I'm going to use
this instead ok bye my falafel that
looks like a falafel Wiener
right you put it in my hot side but now
I'm a bigger one no forward perfect now
we're going to put this lucky garlic
spread the fluff of whatever ah ah ok
that seems like way too much but a lot
of people with tomato and let it in
their falafel so I'm going to put some
chopped tomato and some chopped sled wow
that looks mediocre Wow
this was a long act video well there you
go there is my chickpea nerd here oh no
it appears that we have done something
well guys this is really good granted
there's a lot of much texture happening
but insert sexual joke there once thank
you so much for watching make sure you
click this button to subscribe to this
youtube channel if you're on a desktop
or a laptop and turn on there's a bill
you know like the emoji thing that's
notifications so that you know when I
posted a video and other than that I
don't know and I thought aha what's the
dumbest food of all time is there a
ghost tomorrow but trying to participate
in this video are you at least subscribe